بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين
ان فاذا لتوجيهات خادم الحرمين الشريفين
الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
وسمو ولي عهده الامين صاحب السمو الملكي
الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز
رئيس مجلس الوزراء حفظهم الله ندشن اليوم
حمله التبرعات الشعبيه
لمتضرري الزلزال بسوريا وتركيا وتوجيه
الكريم الذي جاء ليجسد
المعالم
والصفات النبيله التي تتحلى بها قياده هذا
الوطن المعطاء
وشعبه الكريم
ليقوم مركز الملك سلمان
بمشاركه جهات ووزارات سعوديه مهمه
لدعم كل من تضرر واصيب من الاشقاء في
سوريا وتركيا
سوف تكون هذه الحمله حمله شعبيه لجمع
التبرعات سواء من كانت من خلال تطبيق ساهم
او من خلال الحساب البنكي الموحد المخصص
لهذه الحمله او من خلال قنوات التبرعات
المتعدده التي موجوده على موقع مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
ولله الحمد قبل ان تطلق هذه الحمله
تعدت التبرعات اكثر من 13 مليون ريال
سعودي وهذا يجسد الصفات النبيله للشعب
السعودي الوفي الكريم الذي استجاب لدعوه
خادم الحرمين الشريفين وولي عهده الامين
وناكد للمتبرعين ان موقع ساهم اذا
المتبرعين متبرعين بعض التحديات بسبب حجم
التبرعات ان هنالك قنوات اخرى ممثله في
الرقم الحسابي الموحد الذي يمكن التبرع
منه او من خلال القنوات الاخرى الموجوده
على موقع المركز كما اؤكد ان هذه الحمله
سوف
تشكل برامج متعدده سوف يستفاد من هذه
المبالغ من برامج متعدده وجه بها المقام
الكريم لخادم الحرمين الشريفين ولي عهد
الامين سوف يدشن جسر جوي خلال الساعات
القادمه باذن الله لحمل التبرعات سواء
كانت ايوائيه او صحيه او غذائيه كما سوف
تقوم فرق الانقاذ
بالسفر الى مواقع الحدث
لانقاذ المصابين والمتضررين من هذا
الزلزال وسوف تكون هنالك فرق تدخل سريع
وفرق طوارئ طبيه ذات تدخل سريع وكذلك فرق
تطوعيه من الكوادر السعوديه التي تبرعت
بوقتها وجهدها وخبرتها لتخفيف المصاب
الجلل الذي اصاب الاشقاء في سوريا وتركيا
كما اننا سوف نحمل ما نستطيع من مواد
ايوائيه وكذلك غذائيه وصحيه وفقا لما تقوم
به فرق التقييم التي وجه بها خادم الحرمين
الشريفين لتقييم الاحتياج الانساني الذي
يستطيع منها فريق مركز الملك سلمان والفرق
الاخرى لدعم هذه التدخل
نحن في هذا المقام لا يسعنا الا ان نرفع
اسمى ايات الشكر والتقدير والعرفان لمقام
خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي عهده الامين صاحب السمو
الملكي الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز حفظهما الله على هذه المبادره
الانسانيه النبيله والسريعه كذلك لا يسعني
الا ان اشكر الفرق المشاركه التي سوف
تشارك في هذا العمل السعودي النبيل واخص
منها الفرق الميدانيه سواء كانت من
المديريه العامه للدفاع المدني بوزاره
الداخليه او هيئه الهلال الاحمر السعودي
او الكوادر المتميزه من مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه او كذلك
المتطوعون والمتطوعات الذين
بادروا بالتسجيل لدى المركز لتقديم
الخدمات الطبيه والصحيه العاجله في
الميدان كذلك اشكر الوزارات والجهات
الداعمه ممثله
بوزارات الدفاع والداخليه والاعلام
والماليه والجهات المختصه الاخرى اسال
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقنا وان يساعدنا
لتنفيذ التوجيهات الكريمه وان نكون
لدينا القدره والاستطاعه ان نخفف مصاب
اخواننا واخواتنا في كل من سوريا وتركيا
والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته